e
open up the subcommittee
so um I think we all understand the
problem what the issue is here
um so I don't want to spend too much
time rehashing the hearing in terms of
why we need to pass something to deal
with this problem what I want to focus
on is just distinguishing the three
bills and what they do and then um uh
see if we can find consensus to what is
the right answer to go forward
with
so um
first one is um relative to
um in 185 does not set any particular
rates other than that it mandates the
insurance company
simple as that turn you know that there
is no negotiation you know unless unless
of course the the ambulance company
actually had a contract with the um
health insurance company um
assuming they don't because they don't
now for some of them and that so simply
this says that uh whatever the ambulance
company bills them the Ins Insurance
company has to pay for
unfortunately you know I keep talking
about just pay the bill where is it in
company who who says they don't have to
pay the bill well they
full do they they they pay what
they what they want to pay right pretty
much that's the way I see
it you send them a bill for x and they
pay y right well they they have I don't
know any other place that that happens
okay so Mr chair yes represent may I put
something in um isn't the problem that
the entity being buil is not the
insurance company the entity being built
is the patient and the patient is
obligated to pay the bill but the
insurance company um only is obligated
to pay at least according to them what
they've contracted for and most of the
um ambulance providers uh in New
Hampshire are outside the contract and
so no
contract there's no deal to pay
less and if they're representing that
patient for the
bill then they should be paying that I
know if my insurance company doesn't pay
my ambulance bill I'm going to be
why representative sharesa you have a
question uh b i I just want to
understand and I mean this is a
subcommittee we are going to talk about
or is it like is it's not not a hearing
right this is not a hearing this is a
casual conversation trying to try to
among friends so so I I have like some
basic question itself on on this
uh an insurance shall provide
reimbursement for ambulance survey at
the rate negotiated between the insurer
and the ambulance service provider so if
the ambulance service is in network
with the insurance company that's that's
the easiest part because they must have
a contractor rate between them correct
if but so and in that case probably it
might be 50% less than
50% what what were the insurance company
and the provide on the ambulance
services understood as reasonable
because seems to me the rates are not
regulated right now rate can be set by
the ambulance company whatever rate they
want so the problem here I see that in
the absence next line in the absence of
agreed upon rate an insurance shall pay
the amount built by the ambulance
services provider for the service so if
it's out of network then there is no
contracted uh amount and now with this
bill you are saying that if suppose the
ambulance service charge $100 for a
particular service now in network
provider because they might have
contract let's say pay
$60 then they'll pay $60 and both the
party are fine if it's out of network
and ambulance now you're saying that
it's $100 bill the insurance company has
to pay $100 bill which is not fair
because it's it's the same service and
we are now encouraging the out of
network ambulance provider to get more
from the insurance company I think I can
assure you that most of the ambulance
companies are not in network because
they cannot survive on what the
insurance company is offering in network
payments just can't happen and they keep
dangling this in front of us because
they're supposed to be able to push more
patients to them that's what in network
does right you're in that Network we're
going to push patients towards you we're
an emergency service when they're laying
up upside down in their car and they're
not calling the insurance company and
saying hey which Ambulance Service
should I call you dial 911 and we're
coming to get you being in network does
nothing for us except get us less money
I just I just want to clarify one thing
that you know I I know one thing that
the ambulance service providers they are
doing essential service for
medical and and this a required service
I also want to help the ambulance
company but there are few things that
are there in the bills and seems like
the ambulance company they want both
ways which is you know they they they
first of all I saw some other bills you
know that that says that there should be
some some over it on what kind of rate
is being charged for a particular
service I I had asked that question even
uh in one of the hearing to when
gentlemen that uh why the rates for the
same service is different from two
different ambulance companies because
the same service and there's no answer
for that now the thing is that yeah in
in a in a capitalistic model you can put
any amount to any service you want but
here we are talking about you know uh
using uh State influence or using a
regulatory body now to kind of the I
mean bail out in the right word but it's
kind of bail out that okay you help the
insurance you you help the ambulance
services to survive and I do want it to
survive and not only survive but do a
good job but then they also should be uh
monitored by certain regulatory body so
in terms of setting the rates you
realize that 90% of the people that
you're talking about are fire
departments run by the cities and towns
that are not for profit and we're just
trying to cover the T cost of that
taking the burden off some of our
taxpayers is what that is about right
it's not about us making all kinds of
money we're just trying to take the
burden off the taxpayer because it's
not a a if somebody gets sick or injured
it doesn't affect the whole town like a
fire does right right that's why the
fire department's there because if we
don't show up the whole town burns down
so yeah that's a taxpayer burden right
but the ambulance is not a taxpayer
burden it's that person's burden right
and the town is nice enough to set this
up but we have to cover some of the cost
we're not here to make money we're not
here to put the insurance company out of
business the the ambulance line in the
insurance company is like 2% it's not a
big bill for that
but apparently this is the hill they're
going to die
on and I think I already answered that
question in the beginning so I said that
we are definitely because this is
considered to be a essential service and
this needs to not only survive but this
also needs to thrive and do a good
business there's no question on that
that's why we're all here to survive the
thing is that what is but but the
question to and I still didn't get
answer from any of even is that what is
the harm or what is the objection in
having the rate schedule of the
ambulance service to be seen by
oversight committee or maybe Insurance
some committee I don't know somebody so
that the ambulance company do not bill
just like that uh to you know because I
have seen the Medical Billing System in
general when you go to any medical
service you go to a primary care
physician for one vigit 10 10 minutes
viget they charge $400 to the insurance
company insurance company pays $200
maybe maybe less and if you pay cash it
might be less than that the point I'm
trying to say is that what is the approp
roate value of that service because you
know obviously the med the medical
system is surviving with the insurance
company payment to them and not only
surviv they are doing they're making
profits too but so the the what I'm
struggling is that again I'm not expert
in the ambulance billing and I all I
know in general is
that there is a lot of overbilling
happens in medical sub system and I'm
not saying ambulance system is a part of
that or it could be I do not know you
have to educate me on that but I feel
that when somebody sets the rate an
ambulance an insurance company sets the
rate or somebody sets the rate I mean it
it will be totally not only unfair
unrealistic that hey if if a glass of
water cost a dollar I'll say okay I'll
dictate I'll pay only 10 cents insurance
companies cannot say like that I'll pay
only 10 cents that's nego they have to
be reasonable when when when a contract
happen between ambulance company and
insurance company I'm sure both the
parties talk about the realistic cost of
the class of bottle now ambulance say no
I'll charge five bucks insurance company
say no I'll pay 50 cents that's not
reasonable so what I'm trying to
struggle here is that when the insurance
company and again it's in network and
out network is different ball game when
when the insurance company negotiates
the rate with the ambulance provider why
they will force the ambulance provider
to be paid so less that they can't
survive I mean no nobody is blind I mean
even insurance company understands that
part that for this service of a glass of
water which called a dollar you have to
pay something around a dollar you can't
pay 10 cents correct so why tell you
it's a dollar so why do you say pay it's
a dollar we're not we're not trying to
charge $5 for the bottle yeah we're
trying to charge a dollar for the bottle
so why they want to pay us 10 cents okay
you got a point right I mean I I
think has to the reason we're not in
network cuz they want give us the 10
cents and we want the dollar okay we
need the dollar not that we want so then
that needs to be looked upon by some
regulatory body unfortunately this
situation is not as simple as that there
are other factors involved and I think
we should move on a little bit because
we got to touch on all those factors
make a decision is the reason that there
are different costs um in different
areas for ambulance service is that the
actual cost of running the ambulance
service is different in different
different areas as particularly in rural
areas the costs are higher because the
um the geographical area that they cover
is much bigger and at the same time the
number of coals is smaller but they
still have to maintain service 24 hours
a day 7 days a week 365 days a year and
so the cost for each service has to be
higher isn't that isn't that the issue
we're dealing with
that's only part of the
issue yes only part of the issue because
up north they may pay their people a
little bit less but because of the
competition down south they have to pay
their people more so oh you back up to
the same cost so yeah we did a a a big
survey here in the state and the FEDS
did a big survey to come up with the
actual cost of what it cost to run the
ambulance and nobody seems to care about
that okay
so did you have anything else you want
more to say representative spear Gibbs
I'm sorry I said what I wanted to say
thank you okay all right representative
Spear and
then I wanted to go over this um
analysis that uh the insurance
department did for me but I we're not on
that bill yet so right so right now what
I want to do is make sure we understand
what all three bills do and that we can
then disc discuss the pros and cons of
each but once we once we all understand
so does everybody understand what
representative PR House Bill 185 does
everybody but I still have one question
on the last line in that in the bill and
maybe you know someone can answer it
says the provisions of this section
shall not apply to policies that do not
include coverage for ambulance
services
so so this what is that supposed to mean
representative this
I'll have to read it I don't have it
says the provisions of this
section this is uh in the church shall
provide reimbursement no it's it's in
all three paragraph both I can read
again if you want okay so one is one is
um is for the uh I assume group and one
is for individual so it says that the
provisions of the sh shall not apply to
policies that do not include coverage
for ambulet so that means that you there
could be a health insurance policy that
is specifically excludes Ambulance
Service I've never heard of one have you
ever heard of one that did
that so where the hell did that come
from I'm sure there's one out there oh
you sure okay
so question should that be mandated say
he's saying that that was put in there
as a dis that that obviously if your
policy doesn't have ambulance coverage
then this paragraph won't apply so so
let me ask another question that is it
is it mandated uh and again I think
there is no ambulance mandate at this
point in our stat no no I'm saying that
the insurance department person is here
also maybe is it mandator that all the
insurance has to cover Ambulance Service
okay so is it a is it a mandated
coverage or you know what I hate to do
this to but I think you need to have a
microphone okay right why don't you
introduce yourself so everybody in the
committee knows who you
are hi I'm Michelle he and I'm the
director of Life and Health at New
Hampshire insurance department and she's
their legal beagle okay she's their
legal counsel so yes so just to clarify
Emergency Services is an essential um
considered service so it would be
covered under it's part of our Benchmark
plan so it's going to be covered in
pretty much all there is no health
insurance plan now that does not have
this we have no health insurance health
insurance that is a meaningless line
thank
you they don't need next time you put
this bill in make sure you don't put
that sentence hey they put
in I'm just trying to make it in you
know all right so everybody's okay with
understanding what 185 does yep all
right good next is uh 36 well let's do
before we do 316 let's do
all right
so see sponsors
here uh so what we understand when we
read this
bill is that the magic number is
per of Medicare rate of Medicare
rate is there anything else we need to
know more than
that I I'm saying was there is that is
in that the Salient item is that that
the reimbursement rate we're going to
mandate the rate must be
300 25% it's yes it's 325 for a
non-contract assuming that 325 per of
the Medicare rate is higher than what
they charge which is uh not the case for
what do you mean by charge what what
what the ambulance service provider oh
so the ambulance company could build
something less than 325 but we're
assuming that the that the you're
billing they're billing more than the
325 and so therefore this sets a floor
to how much the insurance company has to
pay uh it sets a uh a ceiling right I
the Char if the charges less than than
the 325 they would pay the charges and
and there are some ambulance providers
that would charge less than this amount
according to the things I looked at see
if it was a ceiling you would disguise
the limit right they could pay whatever
I I think we we we agree with uh what
the sentiment is we describe it another
way but that's that's one of the three
elements of this bill that's the key
element right then that's probably uh
the most significant one for for
comparisons all right everybody all
clear on that so 3 half% of The Med
Medicare and Medicare Services exactly
right published rates okay they're
published
rates okay great easy enough and last
but not least oh I I'll just say the
other thing that's different from the
previous bill is that is the prohibition
on Balan
billing
right you didn't have B prohibition on
yours I don't
know okay so his intent is that he
didn't need to have that repeal I have
that requirement because that the
ambulance company is going to get its
full amount makes
sense fair enough so so basically if if
they pay half% then there's no balance
billing to the patient but there's no
need for balance billing in 185 because
the insurer would have to pay the entire
bill so there's no balance for in in in
uh that's true of 185 that's in
185 and and in but in in
725 uh they they did uh they did the
high number the high percentage 325 but
said no they'll there's no balance
Billing at that
point
no and as uh representative PR has
pointed out in the past that 325 still
won't make still won't get the money
that they need okay so now we come to
316 that another one
okay so 316 and yes I am the sponsor but
so I can uh talk about what what's in
this bill and what the intent of the
bill
is in
316 um is saying is that
well we know that whatever number we
pick whether it's well one the bill
that's going to pay pay whatever is
going to be a very high percentage of
Medicare rates
and 325 IS
is um so I I guess this will be my
Mantra is the fundamental problem here
is is is stated right there in in the
concept of the Medicare Medicaid rates
in
which
80% of the
users of
ambulances that's everybody and that's
either transfer or emergency calls or
80% are Medicare Medicaid
patients
80% and yet Medicare Medicaid pays the
lowest amount right because we're
talking like 325 per of that I mean the
lowest
rates so the downside of those bills is
of the insured who are
insured which even of that percentage of
that
177% only seven that so let that's for
discussion purpos say half of that group
ambulance and we're going to ask that
group to
pay for the fact that Medicare and
Medicaid rates are so low
we're expecting them to pay it now
obviously the current statute the
current policy or say the current way we
have been doing
businesses is that that group of PE that
people who are fully insured the
insurance companies going to pay what
they have
their uh guy with the green Shades to
come up and came up with it their their
compensation rate and um the end result
is that an ambulance company has to
balance
Bill what's missing before you make that
statement about balance billing is if
there wasn't any balance billing then
that rate that differential would have
to be paid and let's say with Medicare
Medicaid that differential is paid by
the city in
towns the property taxpayers are paying
that can you repeat the last part last
sentence the property tax if they that
in terms of the current system now which
is that 177% yeah or let's say the
Medicare pay you know which is very low
percentage that all that loss that the
that the money that's not getting
paid right
now the
obligation is the cities and town
property
taxpayer okay they're the ones who are
paying
it okay so over the years the is to say
the city and towns more too crazy
about paying all that
service that the pattern in practice has
been to balance
Bill to they would the fire departments
the amulance companies wherever way
they're organized would then send a bill
to the patient and
said whatever your circumstance is
whether you're a Medicare Medicaid or
whether you're a private insurance this
is how much we got from
them this is our
bill they represent approv this is what
our bill is that difference please send
us the
check and so therefore for the city in
town
taxpayers wouldn't have to pay for it
but if they don't pay for it the city
and town taxpayer has to make up the
differ aren we talking about these
things just because historically that
bill being sent to the person is not
paid most of the time uh we're saying
we've heard we've heard anywhere from 60
to 80% not paid not paid so only 20%
gets
paid 60 to 80% gets paid excuse me 68%
gets paid 20 to 40% does not get paid
so 60 80% gets paid is pretty good
amount of getting paid I know that some
people might not agree with that what is
because I thought that's the problem
that problem they talking stay what do
you think if they get paid what what
Val 20 or 30% actually gets basically 20
30 they're saying it's that low of a
percentage gets paid and so therefore
the remaining balance to make the fire
department or make the ambulance service
get what they need they will they will
then back Bill if you want to call it
that they will then say to the city and
town for us to continue our operation
our services you need to we need this x
amount of money to balance our
Books Okay representative Gibbs thank
you Mr
chair um when I went over these bills
last night and based on the extensive
information that we got during the
public hearing ing um it occurred to me
that there are three things that are
important in all of these bills um one
is that the insurance company pay the
provider directly which I believe all
three bills um are provide um the second
is that there not be balance billing um
because of the problem that that causes
to the patents um and two of the bills
provide that it doesn't apply in 185
because they're the bill from the
provider to the insurance company is the
entire bill so there's no balance left
and then the third is the amount of
money that we're going to require the
insurance company to pay the provider um
and that that amount uh leaves the
provider in a situation where they at
least have a Fighting Chance of not
going out of business and we have to
approach this with the knowledge that we
can't there's nothing we can do about
the Medicare or Medicaid rates because
we can't control the federal government
and there's basically nothing we can do
about the amount of money that the
municipalities have because we don't
control their property tax rates so what
we can deal with is the rates that we're
going to um uh set for the insurance
company I realize this is only going to
be for a proportion of the policies but
again that's all we can deal with that's
all we we have power over and the
testimony from the providers was that
the only um uh setting at which they
would have a Fighting Chance of not
going out of business and I recognize
that this is not going to solve all
their problems but which would give them
a Fighting Chance of not going out of
business um and I recognize that some of
my colleagues are going to strongly
disagree with this but from what they
said that it was it's 325 per of
Medicare as in House Bill
725 um and that seems to me the most
logical thing to
do okay representative
miles thank you Mr chairman um I do
agree with you uh representative Gibbs
um my question
is isn't it better to receive for the
town
325 of
Medicare than
0% of from a balanced bill that most
people just really can't cough up the
pay that's my question I think that's
why we're talking about that we should
uh look towards paying 3 25% is because
balance building definitely looks like
balance building is not working I mean I
don't know where you got the information
that 60 to 80% are getting paid I hear
from them is 20% getting paid I mean
there is no I don't know whether where
the data or who is where did the at the
end of the day if if let's say there
wasn't any balance billing let's say if
we just said no balance billing then
whatever was short would be paid by the
property
taxpayers who have that Ambulance
Company in their Town yeah ly balance
building is not working otherwise uh no
balance building will does work that 20%
I'm sorry that's just not that that may
be their perspective on it okay but I'm
just telling you that I I and and I
guess we can ask people around the room
and how many people have ever had to pay
the balance Bill I know I've done it for
my for my mother and I paid the whole
per okay so I think most people are fine
upstanding citizens and they're and I
the % makes no sense to me but if there
is that 20% that means that all those
people in that Community were fine with
letting the city or town that they live
in make up the difference yeah so and
now I have more hard time understanding
if balance billing is working and if if
it's not being if it if it didn't work
to the extent then City and town is
picking the tab then why the ambulance
companies right now here they are saying
the story that that they are on the
verge of Extinction and they can't
operate properly if nothing nothing done
I have an opinion about that that part
I'm I'm having hard time understand well
let me tell you my opinion isn't the
balance spilling also a serious problem
for the patients we have to also keep
that in mind as well as the fact that
the ambulance companies are never
getting the full amount of what of of
what they need to build that's the point
that I want to
make I have been on this
committee for over 30
years and I have heard this claim that
they are going on a
business all 30
years so why haven't they gone out of
business well that's part I was I'm
going to tell you the simple answer yeah
because they have been able to get the
cities in towns to pay for them and I am
asking you to think there is no
difference
between an
ambulance and a fire Tru or an AM or a
police car in all three cases the town
is providing a service to the community
put do a vital
service okay but that at the end of the
day if they're going to go out of bank
they're going to go bankrupt right
they're going to go out of
business okay is because the city and
town decided not to pay them anymore
that's who would pull the plug because
they are our
Municipal that's who they are yeah and
they have to pay anyway because there
are plenty of private companies out
there but those private companies were
only in the big
cities okay as a matter of fact in my
County we had a private company and it
was in huge financial
distress and yes as sitting as a member
of the executive committee in my County
we got the look at the books and we know
exactly why he was losing a lot of
money because they weren't charging the
cities and towns enough money whatever
the balance billing was and yes it was
65% something like that okay the issue
is here is that is it
fair
that
177% of the popul State's population is
going to fund
the health the to pay for these
ambulances for the
remaining 83% of the
state is that fair but is isn't it the
insurance company and I realize that
this will result in somewhat higher
premiums but what I understood what I
understood from the hearing is that it
would be a few dollars for each person
not a user anybody will spend what they
want but it's like $7 per person you
know per month you know add that number
up it's it's it it would be it would be
the largest mandate we've ever passed
out of this committee if we pass that
number be better to do that rather than
put it on the property taxpayers if we
if we lose one person on the roles of
the insurance because they can't afford
their premiums and it's $7 per policy
per person in the family so if it's a
family of four it's four time 7 if we
lose those people it's going to cost us
a whole heck of a lot more money so
don't be so quick to give away our
insurance premiums and and knock people
off the rolls okay I don't think I'm
giving away anything I'm not finished
yet okay sorry so what happened is this
issue has been around
forever okay and we've nipped in tucked
in we were making sure the insurance
check this past year we made sure the
insurance company's check went directly
to the ambulance and not to the consumer
because the consumer would just cash the
check and and you know like can use the
words of Ken wer woohoo okay
so the issue here is that we all
agree insurance companies can pay
more that is the premise yes and so
therefore what we said is the ask the
insurance
department to have to hire an outside
expert who would collect information
from all these people you see in this
room here yeah they all send
data and come back with a percentage
that is appropriate and not just picked
out of the air like 325 yeah I mean I
think and that's what 316 does but then
why does Maine um have a 400% level
again they pulled the number out of the
air but there is no there is no
Financial basis for the 325 or the 400
any of those numbers
they they just they just winged it so I
agree it should be a negotiated amount
between the insurance company and the
ambulance service we should be just
mandating some percent well no the
percent but but we're uh we're being
thoughtful about this and now we'll look
at this percentage every two
years you know we're going to take the
stat statistical analysis we're going to
bring it in and we're going to be
thoughtful about what that increase so
you know maybe you maybe 204 which is
what I believe we're at you know it's
not right 204 am I get the right number
I believe 202 202 excuse me okay 202 is
what we have you know if we were that
the way at the current analysis who
knows what it'll be from two years from
now but given inflation I'm sure it'll
be higher okay but we're saying is
that's just not just take a number
because we we feel sorry for the
ambulance companies and we feel sorry
for the fire departments and the town in
which have these Services let's just be
rational about it and be thoughtful
about it and come up with a reasonable
number a reasonable percentage that we
know we build into it that it can
grow knowing full well that the real
we're not really solving the whole
problem but we run a chance and I can't
there's no promises here but we run a
chance that once we pass this mandate we
can go back to CMS and ask them to
up the Medicare reimbursement
rate that is the hope we're not
guaranteeing it we know that there's a
wer Pro there are some processes in
which we can make a case that the number
should be a higher number but at least
this legislature is going to do
something because what I'm telling you
is that even if you were to take this
325 we just heard from one of the
sponsors that ain't that won't cover the
problem so they'll be back and they'll
be back again and again and again coming
back with just give us whatever we
and we all know the ultimate goal is
really to get rid of balance billing we
really want to get rid of balance
billing so so the question is how much
do that number should be what's the
rational number that make gets rid of
the balance billing which takes care of
the taxpayer too okay the people who are
doing it okay but then spreads that
balance billing fee over that Community
the the taxpayer in that committee will
make up that difference so so I have two
two questions and comment actually one
is that so are you saying that uh you
are in favor of uh putting a number like
3 25% or are you saying that you are in
favor of having a negotiated contract
between the insurance company and and
and ambulance services so they can
figure it out that realistically and
logically let's say it's 32% or 400%
let's give that amount I'm saying I'm
saying I want you to support my
bill yeah your bill doesn't your bill
doesn't mandate 35% your bill say that
it should be a 204 contracted amount
it's
204 calc you don't see it you won't find
it in the bill but in the bill it says
204% is 204 for this year if we pass it
because we hired an outside consultant
it wasn't done by the department itself
it was somebody else who surveyed all
these people in the
room and they gave them their
numbers and he come back they came back
and said that the right number is
204 and we can't force them to sign a
contract Constitution would not let us
force them to sign a contract so that's
not an issue well then okay I mean I'll
come back to that but another question
that I had to ask you when you're saying
you you mentioned the statistic that 83%
are medic Medicaid patients only 17% are
regular insured how good your
information is where do you get that
information uh this this is this is hard
numbers from the insurance department
okay thank you
so coming back to that percentage so so
you you are proposing 204% some Bill is
proposing 3 25% so basically we are just
throwing a number from different studies
no the
325 IS is they winging it just like
Maine did for for whatever yeah so
that's they're winging the number number
just thrown out exactly and and I I I
feel very I don't I feel that's
irresponsible to take a number like that
I think the right way do it is to
actually figure out exactly what the
insurance companies should be paying
yeah so why why why are we mandating
that should be part why not we let the
insurance company and the provider
provider to sit together on the table
figure it out what is more
reasonable logical and practical number
and let them come up with the number
rather than we dictating that's not our
discussion today did that last year we
did that last year had 30 all my years
that we've asked them why why can't you
guys just work this out and we what we
do know is there some of the companies
do have contracts but we noticed that
those the ones that have contracts are
ones that are in high Urban High usage
areas those are the ones that have the
contracts it's the rural areas the other
FR areas that they don't and the and the
and the finger was being pointed at the
insurance companies that they weren't
paying enough and that's what we're
trying to solve okay I I get I get your
point and uh you know I'm I'm
understanding okay uh but there was one
email that also came one email that come
from one Ambulance Company saying that
Howard Pam is paying 50% me I don't know
it's so many numbers everybody is
sending different different numbers they
are saying har was paying 50% other
insurance paying like 40 30 like that I
think the email came to the whole
committee from one of the ambulance
provider so which number should we
trust how much insurance company is
paying well again in terms of what to
trust is that we uh at this committee
passed last year and I think it was
unanimous and when we P we voted for it
can we can we talk about insur study now
the insurance companies have been trying
to get the ambulance providers to sit
down and sign contracts with them for
years and years and the ambulance
providers won't do it because of the
problems they've explained and we can't
force them to do it we cannot force the
two parties to sign the contract if they
don't want to do it and they don't want
to do
it we are
indirect sorry thank you so I I just
want to pull it back a little bit and
refocus on the specific bills that we're
discussing here so from from a provider
perspective someone that sees patients
and EMS providers every single weekend
when I'm working I just don't think it's
much to ask
if the worst case scenario is to pay $5
more in premium I don't think that's
much to ask to save one person's life if
we if it means keeping one EMS provider
one extra person on so they can go
answer a call while the other two are
busy I don't think $5 is the price of a
life fair enough so representative spe
would very much like to get a little
more understanding about how we came up
with the 202 number so uh can yeah who's
who from the Department would like
to so we
participated at the beginning of the
year uh at the beginning of this
session okay right represent spear first
yes go ahead we participated at the be
uh we asked for last at the end of last
year we asked for the uh insurance
department to contact all of the
providers and give us an analysis of
what it would what it actually
costs uh for various services within the
ambulance providers and they did a study
and I hope everybody read
it but when we had the discussion last
time we were together the ambulance
list and showed numbers that were
considerably higher than what they may
have provided to these
folks and yet it's the same set of folks
providing the information so I asked the
insurance department why are we saying
in this document that ALS support one
non-emergency is $698 and2 and these
folks are saying it's
$2,180 And1 when the when the basis for
this information came from the same
people why are the numbers so
different and so the insurance
department very kindly did an analysis
and they gave me the answer and I'd like
them to go over that with
you you want this or you have it online
so what what was the answer
Carrie I I don't want you to think I
made up anything hear it from the
insurance department thank you so just
to clarify in the ambulance study that
is based off of the gats data the gats
data data has been collected by CMS um
from all of the providers over several
years as part of this study what the PCG
the consultant asked them to do is take
that same gats information and submit it
to them so that they can use that um as
a basis for the analysis so everything
in that cost study is from the data
being provided by the pro um ambulance
service providers um what uh
representative spear reached out to us
is I believe in the testimony there was
a chart um that was provided um that
outlined what the proposed rates are and
compared to what their build charges
were and um for this particular unit um
they had been involved in our ambulance
uh Summit so back when we were talking
about this in the fall of 2023 they had
provided a similar chart to us and um we
looked back at that and we've noticed
that since then their charge rates have
increased dramatically um and so when we
looked at the analysis um given their um
at the time as part of the ambulance
study they gave us their payer mix and
their um the the mix of the different
types of codes that they do so we were
able to actually use that and with the
proposed rates and the information they
gave us for the ambulance study uh for
from the ambulance an Summit um we
actually anticipate that they'd be
getting more money than they were back
then so I'm I mean I can't speak to why
they increased their rates but um you
know we just observe that since so then
to now they've increased their rates D
so sorry sorry to interrupt because we
we use lot of they and they and this and
the numbers can you just clarify a
little bit so understand you put you get
two numbers 2,000 by somebody and then
number came to 698 can you in your
answer say who was $2,000 by given by
whom and how it was $698 part because I
I I could understand that part we just
use they this and you know it more
specific that it be easier yeah so I
believe um tilt and nor tilt and
Northfield fired in EMS is the the unit
we're talking about and they
participated in our cost study so in our
when we
um not in the coste right here but um
the ground ambulance Summit so at the
time of the ground ambulance Summit they
provided us with their charge rates at
the time so for that was
2000 that was for
2022 their rates so we were when we were
talking about this at in the fall of
2023 they gave us their information
which was their most recent data year
for 2022 so in 2022 for als1 their rate
1283 the ambulance
28395 plus mileage and then I believe in
the information that they provided in
the um I'd have to refer back to it I
um so at the time their cost was
1,283 our proposed rate for that same
code so when it say use the word our who
is our here our is from the cost study
that was just done okay so your agency
so sorry your agency you're saying well
PCG the consultant that did it okay
consultant rate that they're proposing
is
1,15 no
1,15 okay and the ambulance agency rate
was 12200 something you said
yes that's what they were charging in
2022 but in their testimony they're
saying now that their rate their current
rate for this year is
2,180 so just from um 2023 to 2025 their
their rate has increased by like 70% and
this is the consultant is saying that
I'm sorry the consultant is saying that
the rate changed from 1,100 to 2,000
something in two years the consultant is
saying not the ambulance
services so their charge rate not what
they are collecting but what they're
billing for that and I was it the
consultant or the ambulance company who
said who gave you the higher rate the
ambulance provider wasn't the consultant
do we have any idea as to the reason for
the difference they would have to speak
to that okay you want to we just
pointing number so can I make a request
please when we use the word we they can
you just say ambulance service Insurance
service and when say they have to speak
means please say ambulance service has
to speak because then I understand who
is they and who is we because it's hard
to follow otherwise uh who is
representing
what I'll try to follow that thank you
so the difference between what we
supplied to the Gat study and what we're
currently doing now is when those rates
identify yourself so you know who we is
sorry the um I'm Michael sear I'm the
chief of the Tilton Northfield fire
district
and when I when I say I'll try to say
tnfd rates in 2022 that was supplied to
gats those rates were an average uh so
I'm uh I have to answer to a board of
fire Commissioners and they set the
rates I don't set the rates the board of
fire Commissioners in in that year were
using the average of what our um billing
company said that we should be using
because of what other people were
charging in our
area and what they had noticed is that
our uh revenues were not matching what
our costs were for the ambulance service
so they asked me to come up with a
formula to to devise how do we actually
what does our Ambulance Service cost our
taxpayers and since I'm a combined fire
department I had to figure out how do I
separate the fire costs
from the EMS costs so I could say say
that if you take an ambulance ride this
is how much it's cost so I came up with
the formula and I don't have it with me
but it's basically we take our operating
budget the total number of calls that we
do in a
year how many of those calls are ems
related that percentage approximately
70% is really what it cost us to run the
ambulance service the other 30% of those
calls are fire related calls so 30% of
our operating budget you could say is
for the fire department I um I have the
document in my phone I probably send it
to you somehow but
anyways That's the basis of it so we
take all of
those transports that so we say there's
1,500 calls and we transported a thou
,000 people that
70% divided by a th000 is what it cost
on the average per ambulance
run so the $1,200 figure was based on
your billing company giving you an
average for for your area and the $2,000
figure was based on your calculating um
an average per Transportation event yes
thank you that's that's the down and
dirty up in the beginning in the
beginning I didn't hear you said that
you're from ambulance services Tilton
Northfield
fire say it again Tilton Northfield fire
fire fire department yes okay so I think
what I what um representative spear
wanted us to clarify to on that is the
way that's described is not an
appropriate methodology that's allowed
under the Gat study that you're not
supposed to be combining those two and
then um portioning off a percentage of
it what the gats did is required much
more detailed cost allocations for um
you know how much are you paying for EMS
Personnel how much are you paying for
ambulance and it goes into a lot more of
that granular detail so in the cost
analysis done by PCG that is not at all
the methodology being used so that's why
there is this huge difference so they're
not going to line up because that's it's
completely different methodology so so
sorry to ask a silly question so what is
gas stand for and what does PCG stand
for PCG is a public Consulting Group
they are the consultant that was hired
um from the legislation last year to do
this work okay what is gats the gats oh
gosh it's the ground
ambulance data collection
survey data collection survey so that
that is owned by ambulance services or
is it independent no it was a CMS
initiative so the federal government had
um put together this initiative and
they've been doing it for for many years
and they're still in the process of
collecting all that data what we TR what
PCG tried to do in this study was
leverage that data that has already been
put together because we were only given
so the department and PCG were only
given a very short amount of time to do
this study so we had to leverage those
um data points that are existing the
gats is a very robust data collection
and has a lot of information and it's
onerous for the ambulance providers to
get that information put it together so
what we were trying to do is leverage
off of all that work that's already been
done and use that as a basis so G of the
federal agency all across the country
yes okay thank you but for this study we
were only looking at New Hampshire
providers okay so in the spirit of
compromise or working forward on
this if were the concerns that maybe
where these numbers were came that
didn't truly ref ref what was going on
in the economy
today we can certainly put off the
effective date to have another study
done but knowing full well that we want
it be done every two years to try to get
the actual dollars but my My Hope was to
pass this and that the new newer dollars
the more expensive they have now will
show up two years from now when we do
this analysis again and then they'll get
higher reimbursement rate the difference
was like couple of hundred like from
12200 to to 2200 it's almost like double
so two agencies studying the same thing
are reporting 1 1200 and
2200 which is a big major gap between
two studies which number is reliable
well again I think that 2000 was not
based off a study that's based off of
the equation that he was just ex that
was the formula that he he he created he
also would have used some data to do it
so right use data but again he was there
was some mixing of apples and oranges oh
okay so should we should we rely on the
number first number I'm sorry to okay
all right here here's the important
thing for me and this this is really
what this is all about and that is we
charge the insurance department when um
to when it comes times for them to set
insurance rates we actually require them
to any insurance company has got to come
in and have some data to defend how they
set that premium yes okay how they said
that and so what we're now doing is
taking that same concept and turning
around and saying is and this is totally
unusual we don't do this with anything
else in the insurance department this is
we're breaking new ground here that
we're asking them to do that same kind
of analysis that's defend our numbers
other words tell us show us your numbers
of how you come to it how and and and
it's got to you know pass the sniff test
for the department and if they if you
know in terms of this formula he has to
defend that formula and how we he's got
to give us evidence and proof that that
formula that he was using was was the
right one okay but that if we if given
what we're about to try to do here is
totally unique here's going to be
glitches I I grant that but all we're
trying to do is say is instead of just
picking a number out of the air and feel
like oh boy we've done
something wouldn't it make more sense
that we've created a rational system
that has is based on real numbers and so
that going forward we'll never have to
see this legislation again that it it
will be resolved until Medicare and
Medicaid finally you know pays a rebirth
all I can say is for anybody who thinks
they wanted to you know Medicare for
everybody take
note what nightmare you are creating
when you think you're going to create
Medicare for everybody representative
Gibbs thank you um although personally I
would rather trust the ambulance
companies or the uh fire department
ambulance services estimation of their
own costs rather than trusting a
consulting company uh nevertheless um
wouldn't it be better to do something
that we can do now rather than wait
months or a year or two years for
another study well that will happen to
your I I was saying if if you guys
really want to delay this to figure out
the right number I just saying is is
that we've got a plan we've got
something in front of us and my best
advice is let's pass
this and and implement this and let's
see how it goes and let's see if now I
guarantee you even if you pass this
325 they'll be be back in two years
telling you the number is too low okay
and so therefore all I'm trying to do is
rationalize a number a reimbursement
rate that in hopes cross my fingers they
won't be back because the data will be
good so data will be right so chairman
hunt on on your proposal assumes that uh
uh they will be in the network with
ambulance so that uh they can work the
numbers I I would have to say is there
in terms of uh the
probability of a u Insurance comp excuse
me an ambulance company getting into the
network is extremely problematic um as
as Mark pointed out it's it's you're
you're not calling your primary care
physician and saying please make a
referral to my in network position my in
network so that just doesn't happen
the only argument I I heard against it
is because the insurance company not
paying them enough that's why they don't
they don't in the network again that's
the only question problem I heard I and
but I will have to say to you that I've
never heard of a hospital or a primary
care physician that ever said that they
thought they were getting paid enough
okay no Pro provider no service and as a
matter of fact when it comes to
hospitals you know we the state right
out big fat checks to all the hospitals
to keep them afloat so you could say
well why don't we use that model and
just be sending checks directly you know
the state should be paying for all these
ambulance companies okay but right now
our system is set up is that that th
those are paid by the cities and towns
who actually hire and operate those
ambulances thank you um isn't there a
federal law called section 1982 which
says that everyone has the freedom to
contract and doesn't that mean that we
cannot force for anyone into a contract
corre no one's talking about who's
talking about forcing anybody into a
contract he's not suggesting that he's
not he was just saying would would what
what will how you work it out otherwise
how do how do you get them to get to a
point of a contract and I'm just saying
oper listic not a requirement from being
here all these years it's just not going
to happen and I'm just saying I agree
with you it's impossible at the moment
good I'm glad we found something we can
agree on well you also you also
mentioned on your uh Bill saying that by
establishing a uniform default rate
schedule how I mean that was the first
uh uh question I asked in the beginning
of our conversation to have why don't
why you have different rates and you you
are putting the same thing that by
establishing uniform default rate
schedule how do you how do you uh how do
we set that rate is we we hire this
outside consultant who gets this data
and that then they will give us the
recommend dat rate so that definitely is
going to serve the purpose that like I
said in the beginning that you know I
still wonder why the rates are so
different by different providers so once
you have the uniform rate at least there
is some common ground I mean it can
differ a little bit depending on
location all those things but it don't
differ like, and 2,000 like we are
seeing in two different studies correct
that's why this is the right
answer did you hear the explanation that
was
given yeah I heard the explanation but
again the that didn't make any sense
that why the difference was so big you
know one of the problems we have is
that a lot of stuff has happened over
the last year and a half or two years
with respect to this and there's a lot
maybe the information is there and it
can be explained and maybe this this
isn't always the best place to do it but
we have a lot of the answers or at least
explanations for what you're
asking so if you want to sit down with
us with me or whoever and and least look
at the history I I sat in on every one
of these meetings and saw the Michelle
hasor Michelle's going to want to speak
to it okay if I may um when when PCG was
conducting the coste I just want to
clarify a couple things that the data
they're looking at is data that the
ambulance providers are providing this
is not independent data this is their
data that they have provided and put
together about what their costs are what
their revenue streams are all of that
very detailed information so it is based
on that but in analyzing the data there
is a wide variation in costs across the
state so part of what they're trying to
do is come up with a rate that's going
to work for the majority of
providers but um there's a lot of
variation based on rality based off of
you know some towns or municipalities
invest more into these things so they
have um you know more resources maybe
than are necessary whereas some maybe
don't have enough resources and all of
that goes into the cost so there is wide
variation among the states so that's
part of the reason why we see these um
huge differentiations so so we all agree
that that definitely needs to be worked
out to have some average not like uh
very like two different exp yes and
that's why if you look at the details of
the cost study it goes into a lot more
of that detail and the the um consultant
PCG um they can be made available um
it's difficult they're out of state the
the lead person who can speak about
everything that went into this study um
so we would have to arrange for her to
come in person for some kind of joint
meeting but we could host the insurance
department can host some kind of Q&A
session if people want to get more into
the details about what was done in this
study but the study is very robust and
there's a lot of information there in
the report so I would just encourage
everyone to look at the report I also
would like to mention that they didn't
come up with one
number for each of the different
Services they came up with a number for
urban a number for Rural and a number
for Super Rural right so they didn't try
to average it all together in any way
they actually tried to break it up by
depending on what kind of conditions
they were in the study itself is is
pretty self-explanatory and it's really
quite good just one more thing to add to
is the study does adjust for inflation
so even though the the data is coming
from various years that data was
adjusted to account for medical
inflation yeah so as long as the
ambulance services they stick to those
like you say even three subcategories
rural urban town whatever as long as
their rates are in line with those
readings then you can say as your as
your bill says have a uniform rate
schedule uniform doesn't mean that same
rate but at least pertaining to or
sticking to that standard being set by
someone rather than having your own rate
right it's a rational it's a rational
number rather than just picking a number
out of the sky
yeah just one more thing to add to um
with respect to Contracting this rate
would set a floor there would be nothing
prohibiting um the parties into entering
to a contract at some other
rate say it again this would this rate
if it were to pass would set a floor so
it would there would be no prohibition
the party still could contract and come
into Network and negotiate a different
rate which is what you're' been
suggesting yeah I mean that that again
they might they might look at that
number and say well maybe it's time to
go into a contract and get a higher
number well as long as agreeable by both
the parties then both the parties are
happy exactly
exactly okay so um it is quarter to
three um this bill um if I'm correct
this is the only 38 is the only one is
an early
bill so just one more comment say say
that again chairman hunter that this
bill and I just want to make sure want
316 uh no no 316 is not an early
Bill okay which one one of those was an
early Bill wasn't
185 so 185 is the one bill we need to
is wanted to P the first one let me let
document we're talking 185 right see
this says says it's not who who has a
computer's 36 what does it say on the
question chman what is the question
represent excuse me Mr St you can come
up and speak he's trying to figure out
which bills have to be done early so it
says 185 on
theet that was that was my brother sorry
so I think 185 is the only one I got to
get get out today oh that's this week
6 go ahead what do you got to say thank
you uh Chris STW Hall Hampshire I just
point of clarification and you mentioned
it that your mom got a balance Bill I'm
going to assume your mom's on
Medicare my mother at the
[Music]
time yeah yeah she probably was on medic
okay Medicare Medicaid Commercial
Insurance Medicaid we can't balance Bill
anybody take what the state determines
is the rate Medicare sets an allowable
rate and then they only pay you 80% of
that rate you are federally required to
balance bill that amount so that's never
going to go away no matter what we
do and the commercial
rate we balance bill because we feel
that the reimbursement is inadequate and
that's where I got my 20% from so I'm
I'm not including the Medicare piece
because we can't stop doing that no
matter what we all want to do in this
room that's still going to happen for
everybody I just wanted to clarify that
right isn't that interesting that they
fixed it for their air ambulances but
they left that one and and just one more
point the company that I worked for for
31 years which serviced nashille and
Manchester yes did go out of business it
was Rockingham ambulance I spent most of
my life there and now I'm with someone
else so it does happen so what happened
to to all the trucks and all that that
they didn't even sell the company they
liquidated it it was part of St Joseph's
hospital and they hospital hospital and
they couldn't afford to run it
anymore so that Hospital's gone too
to okay so um theoretically uh we we can
we can spend a little more time more
more thinking about this we don't have
to make answer the one bill that I would
kind of hope uh we would take up or we
can wait till next week because I think
I had it schedule again next week um is
the is is this three is uh the
185 so so chairman one question we so
far we have talked about you know
Medicare Medicare and insured right how
how do we address our do we even address
the one who are uninsured and and they
they take the ambulance and how how that
that is dealt with or it was just uh
well you know the good news is the
uninsured is only about 5% and uh um but
yes it is true that they they would just
get balance bills and and they just pay
I'm pretty sure they don't
probably I don't know do they go to the
town welfare department does W I don't
know I don't know how so we don't have
to worry about that only at this point
the problem the meat of this bill the
meat of these issues is that we're
looking at the fully insured Market
because the assumption
is insurance
company insurance have the de pocket all
right and the rap and the people who who
they have a system to be able to balance
Bill all the premium
payers okay that if we stick it to them
then they'll just they'll just pass it
on and we'll all pay higher premum all
of us who fully insured will pay the
higher premium okay not me anymore
because I'm I'm I'm over 65 now okay but
for my
employees I as a small employer I would
have to pay the de so the issue is is
that do this as a solution because other
states have done it that way or should
we find a good long-term
solution that is fair fair urb maybe
doesn't give enough money to some
people's mind but at least it's fairer
than having this current system which is
it's a it's basically a user fee and
that's what balance billing is it's a
user fee you know you use it you're
going to get you're G to have to pay and
and but because it's Municipal people
you know stump their nose and say you
know turn it into a paper airplane and
throw in trash can so it's more of a
collection issue right now it is right
now if if everybody paid that bills if
that if they B balanced billing was all
being paid then there wouldn't be a
problem except that people come back and
say to us you've got rid of balanced
billing for everything else why haven't
you got rid of balance billing for this
one
category so representative GBS thank you
um I'm gonna run something up to the
flag poll and see if anybody
salutes um uh the suggestion is that the
subcommittee recommend um itl on HB 185
with the understanding that either 316
or 725 will be
true uh that would that would solve that
one bill yeah the I just said that it it
can directly reimburse the ambulance
provider yes it says that they pay the
entire bill which I don't think is going
to FL why can't we just why can't we
just itl 185 without any other
conditions attached to we would we yeah
we we understand we're going to come
back and do something oh you I I am
bound and determine to pass something
and yes I am you know as as everybody
knows
I'm I I I have very strong feelings and
yes I think the bill that I put in even
though it has my name on
it you know support of what the
committee the committee unanimously
agreed to last year so I understand so
but at this point if uh you know if if
we just uh um itl 185 that would solve
the the the problem for NE you know get
get past that yeah because if you are
struggling on 35% how can this bill says
okay okay so we ready to take action on
everybody 18
sheet okay um after long long
discussion much much see the tape you
took no
to okay
uh representative Gibbs are you going to
make the motion to inex speed the legisl
I
move I move that
um HB 185 be here okay so I have a quick
question on that though yeah I mean over
let me just take this motion first okay
okay we have a motion second by
representative gives for inex speing to
legislate uh we're now open for
discussion so the question was that in
the analysis portion it says you know
for the full amount that's why we it
Ling but in the next page it does say
somewhere that in the absence of agreed
upon rate an insurer shall pay the
amount built by the ambulance service
provider for the service subject to
review by the insurance department oh
but it also puts in the event of a
dispute dispute yes okay I guess that's
fine
yeah I thought they going to rev you'll
put it in again next year two years from
you
okay all right the motion is for in
expedience of legislate on House Bill
185 having our discussion all those in
favor please say I I one two three four
five six
seven those
oppos use mov
unanimously okay great we're we're done